to understand how closely related we are
to chimps and bonobos we're more closely
related to them than an Indian elephant
is to an African elephant so whether you
look at in terms of DNA or how long it's
been since the lines the evolutionary
lines diverged and it's important to
know that we're equidistant from chimps
and bonobos so anytime you read that
chimps are the closest non-human primate
to to us or conversely that bonobos are
the closest they're both false chimps
and bonobos are equidistant from humans
as close as your left hand and your
right hand are to your head they're
exactly the same distance so it's very
important to understand that now on one
side you've got chimps who are very
aggressive there's evidence of warfare
between groups murder is relatively
common rape is common infanticide all
sorts of aggressive behaviors is rampant
in societies but on the other side you
have bonobos who are very highly
sexualized and in which over forty years
that they've been observed in the wild
and in captivity not a single case of
murder or infanticide or rape or lethal
combat between groups has ever been
observed not in zoos not in the wild so
they're sort of the light in the dark
side of human nature we could say and
it's important not to fall for this line
that we're closer to chimps and
therefore the the nasty aggressive dark
side of man is one book puts it is more
deeply embedded in us than the other
side what we all share the three of us
the chimps the common chimps the bonobo
and humans is a an exaggerated sexuality
where the vast majority of the sexual
behavior that we experience has nothing
at all to do with reproduction over 99%
of our sex acts don't result in
conception that's very unusual in the
animal world most animals including most
primates other than the three of us the
chimps bonobos
humans might have sex a few times a year
gorillas for example probably have sex
10 to 15 times for each baby gorilla
that's born now you think about how many
times an average human being has sex
over a lifetime and I'm not only talking
about intercourse think of all the types
of sex we have they can't possibly
result in conception it's a very small
percentage of our sexual behavior that
really has anything at all to do with
reproduction we share this trait with
chimps and bonobos we split from them
about 7 million years ago so according
to conventional thinking and
evolutionary theory if a trade is shared
between these 3 species that separated 7
6 to 7 million years ago it's very
likely that that trait was shared also
by the last common ancestor so we can
look back 6 to 7 million years and say
that has been 6 to 7 million years of
human primate promiscuity pretty much
uninterrupted until we get to 10,000
years ago with agriculture and the
advent of monogamy so that gives you a
sense of why it's so difficult for most
people we've been you know going down
this the same path for so long and then
suddenly we're told no no that's not the
way we behave anymore and in fact that's
not natural so if you behave that way or
you want to behave that way or you
fantasize about behaving that way or you
get off on watching other people behave
that way there's something wrong with
you you're sick there's something wrong
with your relationship if you think
about someone other than your husband or
wife every time you have sex there's
something wrong with you or something
wrong with him or her that's all wrong
that's that's not only wrong but it
creates untold suffering in people
because they feel shame about something
there's no reason they should feel shame
about
you